[inaudible]
on the 1st of July,
visio Canada celebrated it's 150th
birthday.
Now we told you all about this in a
previous video where we also showed you
some of the keys as Dwight Canada is one
of the most admired countries in the
entire wells,
kinda instability to into 10 provinces
and three territories just have so many
unique regulations that in 2017 they
actually had to sign a free trade
agreement among them.
However,
even though this country is turns 150 in
perfect shape,
Canada is also facing problems.
Faye,
social,
political and economic threats that
could be considered.
Well,
pretty serious indeed because as you
probably already know,
well,
unfortunately nothing is perfect.
So in a previous video who's link I'll
leave at the end of this video as well
as in the description below.
We looked on the bright side of things
and Canada ended up looking pretty darn
wonderful.
But in this video we're going to discuss
the main problems and threats that are
affecting Canada and well the first of
them,
it's got a lot to do with this 150th
anniversary birthday.
Somehow artificial Canadians not even
close,
celebrated this 150th birthday.
We can find several different reasons
why,
but in order to explain them,
we should first tell you about what
happens 150 years ago,
so that's jumped back in time all the
way to 1867 on the 1st of July of that
year.
The territory was still a part of the
British empire,
but it was on this day for the first
British North America Act was signed.
The British North America Act of 1867
was a law that united the three colonial
provinces of New Brunswick,
new Scotland and Canada,
which is divided up into Ontario and
Quebec.
That very same day into the
Confederation of Canada of these four
provinces,
which still counts quite a loss of
autonomy.
A federal government was organized to to
give them some cohesion above this
government's,
there was still the British authorities.
Thanks to this day,
Canada is still a monarchy and Queen
Elizabeth.
The second is still the head of state.
Also Bams,
although it might sound surprising,
Canada didn't have to till independence
from the UK until very recently.
1982 in fact,
that's right.
Something's on 1982 any constitutional
modification required to the approval of
the British parliament.
So as you can probably see from this,
that law in 1867 it didn't result in a
completely independent country bus Dev
you is.
That's not the ends of it.
There are more reasons why Canadians
dislike this day.
The most important of these is that when
the settlers arrived,
Canada,
well,
it wasn't an empty lands
first nations,
the inuits and the,
yeah,
it's 1.5 million inhabitants said
nothing to celebrate last July and those
inhabitants my own v within natives of
Canada,
it's a celebration of the worst 150
years up indigenous peoples lives.
Don't think of this as only a historical
problem.
The recognition and integration of these
people's,
it continues to this day to be a
national problem.
In fact,
the government of Justin Trudeau,
it hasn't made it a priority.
Consider all the prime minister had to
say on the 21st of June of this year.
No relationship is more important to
Canada.
Then the relationship with the
indigenous peoples,
Justin Trudeau.
Oh,
you might be wondering,
Hey,
all these groups sounds,
what has happened to them over the last
150 years?
Yeah.
According to the Canadian constitution,
there were three large groups.
The first nations made of more than 600
native communities.
The inuits,
the people of the Arctic and the
methods,
the result of mixing natives with the
new settlers.
Canada was not an empty land.
When the settlers arrived,
it's actually estimated that there were
around 500,000 people from these needs
of communities who signed the agreements
with the British and the French
authorities.
They even participated in the battles
that protected the independence of
Canada.
Canada would be American today,
if not for the Indian allies who fought
for the crown.
Peter Russell.
Oh yes.
The U s really did try to invade Canada
more than once.
While.
The problem is that despite his being
the first people in this land and
despite the fact that they participated
and contributed to the independence of
the country,
the natives suffered a clear cultural
pass,
a key.
Oh Shit.
Yup.
As a result of that obsession,
somehow to create a homogenous and
national identities kind of just went
through a period of persecuting the
natives.
For years,
these people suffered the occupation of
their territories and were sent away to
reservations,
which sometimes didn't even have the
basic conditions that would allow for
their survival.
Furthermore,
both their language and their cultural
and religious rituals where sometimes
forbidden this persecution,
it reached such a point that the
authority set up a system of residences
and boarding schools for the children of
native families.
The government took the children from
the families and sending them to schools
where they would receive an education
which was fully western so that they
could lose all aspects of that cultural
identity.
Tens of thousands of children,
they were educated in
this way
and these schools,
they continued until the 1970s and the
consequences,
they still have to be dealt with today.
Poverty rates are much higher than
average.
There are many broken families.
Depression is rampant.
Alcoholism and suicide rates are higher
than average.
Yeah.
All the consequences,
all of this sorts of persecution along
with these at racism and exclusion,
we're also very normal.
Sorry.
In 2008 the prime minister at the time,
Stephen Harper,
apologized to these people's for the
atrocities and established the truth and
Reconciliation Commission.
Sure.
Speaker,
I stand before you today to offer an
apology to former students of Indian
residential schools.
The treatment of children in Indian
residential schools is a sad chapter in
our history.
They've also paid hundreds of millions
of dollars in reparations.
That money can't fix all these problems.
Even today,
Canada is still looking for the best way
to move forward from this dark period of
its history,
but now let's step back forward to the
present day and look at the relationship
between Canada and the u s oh well more.
Absolutely.
Canada and president
from [inaudible].
The breakup threat
is very dependent on its relationship
with the United States.
They are so dependent that we could
almost say that the Canadians would be
unable to live without best southern
neighbor.
Indeed,
almost 70% of Canadian trade is bound
for the United States,
but at the industrial sector of both
countries,
it's strongly interconnected.
So this is a special relationship and
this is something Justin Trudeau knows
indeed.
He said so in his campaign,
and as soon as he reached power,
the concentrated is international
affairs and to improving Canada's
relationship with the United States.
And so truth be told is the relationship
that he built with Obama.
Thank you again for your leadership and
your friendship.
I know that our two countries can
achieve great things by working together
as allies and as friends as we have done
so many times
before.
There's some things we will probably
never agree on who's beer is better,
who's better at hockey?
Trump's in office and is pursuing a
policy of protectionism Canada.
What they've done to our dairy farm
workers is a disgrace.
It's a disgrace.
And so what did the Canadian government
do?
Well,
they set up something of a war room.
This was an office dedicated to
following all the movements of the new
administration in Washington.
At first,
the strategy of Trudeau and his people
was buttering up the American
government's and is it kind of looked
like it was working.
The Canadian Prime Minister even started
a friendship with Ivanka trump.
Trump's daughter Justin Trudeau,
brings Ivanka trump to Broadway show on
welcoming outsiders.
As you can imagine,
this opened the door to all sorts of
wild rumors and speculation.
The thing is they got on well and both
have led a seminar on women in business.
Donald Trump himself mentioned in a
speech to Congress with the help of
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau.
We have formed a council with our
neighbors and Canada to help ensure that
women entrepreneurs have access to the
networks,
markets and capital they need to start a
business and live out their financial
dreams.
Donald Trump.
All right.
I say this was all great.
It seemed to be working really well.
Bob's then all of a sudden trump attacks
and accused Canada rather.
I've done expectedly of unfair
competition.
Something that he also did with Mexico,
right?
It would be really dangerous,
but Canada to suffer a restriction on
trade relations with the u s government
in Ottawa decided to start these so
called a doughnut strategy consisting of
influencing all institutions around the
White House,
which would be considered as being in
the center of that hole of the day.
The question it now becomes,
will they achieve that goal?
No.
Lead time will say,
the first challenge is to renegotiate
Nafta as trump has demand it.
Now,
next step,
we need to consider another essential
crisis that could threaten Canadian
prosperity.
Okay.
Real estate bubble.
Hmm.
Prices and Canada's housing market,
they have absolutely skyrocketed.
They've increased 76% and so have the
loans that banks are providing.
Indeed it.
Family debt in Canada is now among the
highest in the world.
Have a look at this chart.
Do you see the increase in Canadian real
estate prices?
And then we'll
what's considered family.
But as you
measuring this is set off all sorts of
economic alarms.
Many analysts foresee at the popping of
the Canadian real estate bubble along
with all the consequences that that
would have on its economy.
And look,
almost 7% of the country's employments
belongs to the construction sector and
thanks to this mortgage boom at three
Canadian banks are now in the top 20
banks worldwide.
In fact,
the market value of the Royal Bank of
Canada is higher than that of any bank
in the eurozone.
Okay.
As everyone knows,
the consequences of the real estate
bubble bursting would be pretty dire to
doing something about.
This has to come another priority of the
Canadian government,
the government's,
it's trying to stimulate other sectors
as well.
Cooling down the real estate market,
maybe the intention,
so you increase the arrival of
immigrants by 50% every year.
It has a lot to do with this.
More immigrants means more demand for
real estate,
but other experts,
they disagree with this and state.
The Canadian banks were not affected by
the 2008 crisis and that they are quite
a bit more solid than other
international banks and also the economy
in Canada.
It's doing quite well and is gaining
strength after some pretty mediocre.
Yeah.
Yes.
Anyway,
time will tell,
but this is a risk that the government
is going to have to look out for.
All right,
so now let's move on to the matter of
public services.
Okay.
The waiting lists.
Health is a public service which is
managed and financed by the governments
with the citizens and its taxes.
Of course,
this system is considered to be one of
the best in the world.
However,
they have recently had to deal with some
very serious problems and most important
of all of these problems is the issue of
waiting lists.
According to the Fraser Institute,
the average time to see a specialist is
18 weeks.
That's more than four months,
and the demographic of the aging
population and the increase of life
expectancy has made it difficult for the
system
cut
resulted in tens of thousands of
Canadians and moving to the u s to
receive medical attention lately that
has even popular to take our medical
insurance in the United States.
Anyway,
these are the main challenges and
threats to the government of Justin
Trudeau.
Like we said earlier,
not everything,
and be sunshine and lollipops and
rainbows,
but you know what we think are the
overall results of the Canadian
cocktail.
Well,
we think it looks pretty good.
So now it's your turn.
What do you think of Canada and their
systems?
Do let us know in the comments below.
And also don't forget to subscribe to
our channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday.
I'd also don't forget to check it off,
friends at being reconsidered media
podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine.
And there's always off.
Thank you for watching.